I love your dress by the way thank you
you always I'll see if I can find you
you always look so beautiful have you
seen my Instagram yes in fact I want to
bring that up you had a black eye
recently I still have a black eye but
the funny thing was the first time I was
supposed to come on the show I got a sty
so I thought I I can't I can't go
they're going to you know who knows what
they're going to say about me so I
cancelled yes we rescheduled because
it's medical and that's important last
Thursday vanity show of pivots thday
with the Real playing pickle
ball ball hits me in the eye first thing
I thought I'm going to have to cancel
Drew
again who were you playing pickle ball
with was it your amazing husband David
Kelly no I do play with my amazing
husband David Kelly um but I was playing
with my sisters Deee and Lori and Lor
Dee and Lori and a couple of friends of
Lor's and it was
the the the friend who hit me in the eye
and he was horrified of course he
couldn't even speak to me he couldn't
even like look at me um okay is it true
that when you met your
husband or you were being set up on a
blind date and you actually thought that
maybe he and your sister would make a
good match I did well only because he
wasn't speaking to
me and somehow well I did a bad thing
where where were you on this blind date
so it was a blind date but I decided it
should be a group
date I I still don't know why that was a
bad idea I don't actually think it's a
bad idea a little social cushioning
absolutely fine no no this I think this
isart it didn't go well though how come
because we were in this restaurant and
there were eight of
us and somehow he ended up sitting
across from my sister and I I ended up
sitting across from his best friend we
didn't speak the whole night and then he
left early to go to another
party I thought okay that went
well um yeah so how did you end up find
well you know then he actually finally
called me two days later that was also
not okay the classic two days but so two
days later he called you he called and
we ended up talking on the phone for
about an hour and it just went like that
and so you just celebrated 30 years so I
[Applause]
[Music]
mean